this is eight news now live at four live
local now right now at four the search
for answers after two people were shot
and killed in a northwest valley
neighborhood thank you for joining us at
four i'm kirsten joyce and i'm christian
cassette as that shooting happened on
glowing ember court near the 95 and the
215 in centennial hills joe muller is
live this afternoon with what people who
live nearby are saying joe
right now this neighborhood is pretty
quiet but just 24 hours ago is a
completely different story those shots
were fired here from this home again on
glowing amber courts right next to daisy
pedal those bullets went flying
throughout this neighborhood and just
take a look across the street here at
this garage door you can see where one
of those bullets ended up hitting now
people we talked to in this neighborhood
say they still have a lot of questions
about what led up to this sort of
violence
i was getting ready to take my dog for a
walk what started out as a typical
monday afternoon it's scary because
i mean this could happen anywhere
quickly turn into something else a
little after four not just once it was
bang bang bang bang bang bang at least
eight nine times gunfire a sound nicole
bowden says she hasn't heard here before
take my dog for a walk and
got halfway up the street when
all the squad cars started showing up
streets were closed and caution tape was
up police say two people were shot and
killed and another one injured at the
home behind bowdoin on glowing ember
court during an altercation bullets went
flying in the front yard even hitting
nearby homes and that's the thing that
scared me was it was right
next to my backyard so it could have
easily went through
a kitchen window
tuesday the house looked like every
other one on the street i said
i love this neighborhood and it's
been quiet now it's all a mystery to
people here pack of ferrari is left with
questions no yeah you know what's really
going on people i spoke with did not
know who lived there almost every night
i've seen people coming out and say
hello hi how you doing tonight that's it
bowden is also left with a lot of
questions i want to know what happened
now back out here live the police were
out in this neighborhood today going
door to door asking questions if people
knew any information about the people
who lived there they did not provide any
sort of update to us today and the
motive as of right now is still not now
reporting live in centennial hills john
waller live local now